now you'd be excused for thinking the
greatest star the world has ever known
was in town this week
such was the adulation and adoration
heaped upon them okay she's cooler than
an icebox classier than a catwalk full
of models and sassier than the hippest
hipster dude on the planet she's been a
loyal wife to her husband stepped up to
be the breadwinner so he could enter
politics and seems to have pulled off
the near impossible by raising two
daughters to become well-adjusted
grounded young women despite growing up
in a goldfish bowl world of unwavering
inspection but as supporters swoon and
say she empowers women is the perfect
role model and campaigner the
deification continues but what has this
person actually achieved I've seen no
problem with this but much of the world
loves Michelle Obama because she's black
the first black first lady in the White
House good luck to her but let's get
real plenty of other first ladies have
been Doughty campaigners this seems to
be her biggest achievement before I well
I have to show you what we got here very
proud of myself this is her show what
did you learn from her show I learn a
lot I just talked about this I'm gonna
talk about Michelle Obama herself and
clearly you are no student of history
and I have to say as a black woman I'm
completely offended that you think she's
saying offend you I didn't set out to
offend you but I'm telling you so if you
look at first ladies if you look at the
first ladies that have been America's
most beloved first ladies
we'll start with Dolly Madison who's the
one who actually created the role of
first lady and at the time you know
women were second-class citizens and she
created a role for the wife and for the
spouse of the president and then if you
look at the other two Eleanor Roosevelt
and Jackie O
the ones that people have loved the most
are white they were not just loved
because clearly they weren't black sure
but you've got to look at why people
love them so with Eleanor Roosevelt she
was somebody that was able to connect
with the poor she was the one that was
able to take messages back to her
husband the influence than you do if you
look at Jackie O she bought a certain
level of style sure to the white house
animal and change the way that America
saw itself in the way the world saw
America I would say that Michelle Obama
is a unique combination of those two
women which is why people love her she
has the depth of Eleanor Roosevelt have
to be physical they can affect a change
she's got great upper and yes in the
country or in the world I think and him
White House gave lots of black people in
America hope for their people there were
fewer obstacles in the way of black
people and more possibilities were
opened up and I think it also confirmed
deep-seated truths about things like
black excellence about humanity about
love because remember election day in
2003 remember I remember clear you say
it's not about black people it was but
on the television people black men and
women were interviewed and I don't think
I've ever seen that kind of ecstasy at
any election in my life before they felt
massive hope because they were there and
I think that is their achievement okay
let's get the others first I don't think
I agree we I'm asking for her chief I
love them no no I think her greatest
achievement is she's authentic the
people that people yeah that's what she
is that's who's huge she brought up a
kid she she admits in the book that she
and baracoa haven't always had the best
relationship all that sort of stuff
I mean it's if you saw with James Corden
sort of doing she was brilliant she got
some publicity but being the first black
lady there's no there's no but something
something special I think that you are
this is a classic example of the male
gaze at a female and you don't you're
not taking into account all these sort
of unpaid emotional labor of the woman's
role and now I'm gonna move on to
Michelle Obama
she took the back seat she did she was
the home all over the rest of it in the
White House alone she she started a
number of important nationwide has yes
but still she did it but she has been an
advocate for all women not just black
women for example when Trump won the
White House or was trying to get into
the White House and said with women you
just grab them by the you-know-what
let's hear what she had to say then this
was not just a lewd conversation this
wasn't just locker room banter and I
feel it so personally and I'm sure that
many of you do too particularly the
women the shameful comments about our
bodies the disrespect of our ambitions
and intellect the belief that you can do
anything you want to a woman it is cruel
it's it's frightening and the truth is
it hurts I think you can feel the name
check can i name check so on she has
written a book that has sold two million
copies to date but on its first day of
publication
seven hundred
I take it all back the actual
achievements so in 2010 she launched
let's move the campaign which is today
managed to get over 45 million young
people eating healthily in America and
actually is a healthy country and
tackling the childhood obesity rates
then in 2011 she established the joining
forces program this has been phenomenal
it's managed to get 1.5 million
experts into work and their family then
we have the reach higher initiative
which was to inspire young people across
America to carry on with their education
past school okay and then in 2015 the
let girls learn campaign and this has
been a phenomenal initiative helping
girls around the world other first
ladies have had great campaigns as well
about addiction about education because
Let's Move and particularly the military
veterans campaign there was a piece of
the New York Times and she's got a
portrait and there was a load of young
girls and women standing around it and
they're going oh god she's inspirational
she's wonderful she's sisters that the
reporter asked them why they thought she
was all of those things and what she had
done that inspired them and they
couldn't tell it well what you're
getting my mother said would always tell
me I'm raising adults I'm not raising
babies so her philosophy was that we
could understand a lot if she took the
time to explain it so it was never speak
only when spoken to she encouraged us to
let our voices be heard and I talked
about this earlier today when I was with
the girls at the Elizabeth Garrett
Anderson school which we had a wonderful
time one of the things that my parents
but believed was that my voice was
relevant and my opinions were meaningful
and my anger and frustration was real
she is an example of excellence for
everyone men and women you could learn a
thing or two I'm sure there was a poll
done by you gave of the world in Britain
of the world's most admired women she
only came second who came first Angelina
Jolie very very briefly I had June on my
LBC radio show we did the same thing and
then all were you listening then all the
listeners piled in I reckon I lost by
about 15 to 1 at the end I said I said
this just because June's right it
doesn't make her a better